I've had a number of viewers asking me
if I wouldn't shoot some videos on unlit
Vic Pitkin Stein and specifically on two
of this works one emblematic of his
early phase the Tractatus
logico-philosophicus and the other taken
to be sort of the the best expression of
his mature work where he actually
repudiated the track taught us the
philosophical investigations and I will
shoot videos on those although there's
going to be some delay because I have
some other projects in the workings
right now but what I wanted to do with
this video is is to talk about my own
philosophical development and what I
call my VidCon Stinney interphase
because there was a time where I was
really captivated by the Kitsch 9 and
reading him and thinking about him a
good portion of the time it was not
quite as long as you know what I would
call my sari and her Nietzschean phases
and in some ways it didn't run quite as
deep for for reasons that I'll talk
about a little bit later on in the video
when I talk about why I got out of it
Kim Stein but I will just say this what
what I was what I was getting into and
why I was attracted to Vic in Stein I
found some very interesting material for
for pondering and reflecting in his
works but then I also found that a lot
of other people were doing similar type
of work and sometimes doing it quite a
bit better in ways that were more
informed in ways that that you might say
had greater potential for doing
something with it
so that's why I end up leaving Victor's
sin behind but I I went like again I did
go through a period where I really was
in a phase where I was trying to see
everything through the lens of Vicki
Stein and that was mostly in graduate
school and it was early on in graduate
school my first several years it didn't
go on after that because I got into
semiotics and other other things in the
philosophy of language and dialectical
philosophy and so I ended up leaving
Wittgenstein behind the first book that
I ever read by Vic enstein was was
neither the tract honest nor the
philosophical investigations but instead
it was his uncertainty which was given
to us as a reading for our contemporary
philosophy class which which was a kind
of weird class it covered a bit of
analytic philosophy and Vik and shine
fit into that I covered process
philosophy pragmatism and existentialism
that was that was the field of
contemporary philosophy where I I went
to undergraduate they they basically
thought that philosophy had had more or
less come to a close by 1950 or 1955 so
this is an interesting work and and I I
liked it quite a bit I really enjoyed
the the approach that they were taking
in it he was interested in this question
what is what does it mean to be certain
why why are we driving after that how do
we use the language of certainty belief
knowledge and he was exploring avenues
that I hadn't seen too many other people
doing so you know for example he he says
I know seems to describe the state of
affairs which guarantees what is no
guarantees it is a fact okay so far so
good right you get that out of out of
many thinkers and then he says one
always forgets the expression I thought
I knew so what we had here was a thinker
who was very attentive to
the the ordinary context that oftentimes
we would end up losing sighted and
thinking that it had something to do
with with the concepts that we're trying
to explain so I like that very much
about fit connect Vidkun Stein is in
some ways a pioneer in the philosophy of
language and he certainly had an
important effect on anglo-american
philosophy not not so much on other
other domains he really had practically
no influence whatsoever on French
philosophy on German philosophy on
Italian philosophy but he exerted a
great influence in the anglo-american
world which by that point had gotten
itself into some some dead ends and he
helped to get get them out of those dead
ends unfortunately they were in those
dead ends in large part because of
rejecting the entire heritage of
philosophy before them and managing to
misunderstand most of that and to
disparage it and leave it behind so you
know the dead ends that he was getting
them out of were things that they could
have had other ways to get themselves
out of John wisdom is a great example of
somebody who actually did do that by
looking at alternate sources and
engaging them but Vic constrain is
responsible for the turn to ordinary
language and paying attention to the
grammar the logical grammar of our
statements or questions are assertions
you know talking about concepts belief
in a very pragmatic way as being this
sort of network that we are involved
with and
sort of presuppose in order to make
sense out of out of the things that
we're talking about victims shown also
have this very therapeutic conception of
philosophy which which I don't actually
enjoy much or I'll really say respect
much or share where the goal is to let
the fly out of the fly bottle and I'll
talk a little bit more about that in a
few minutes but not in case Vidkun Stein
was an assert an important philosopher
because he he ended up influencing other
people in in the world of anglo-american
philosophy who ended up saying some
interesting things as well and I don't
just mean people like like you know rile
or Austin I also have in mind people
like like out like Ambrose and geek and
people like that who had somewhat of a
better grounding and the classical
tradition and understanding of Thomas
Aquinas or Aristotle
now it's interesting Alistair McIntyre
in a an interview that he gave in in
Kinesis at one point is asked about
Heidegger and says that he considers
Heidegger to be important to learn
because he led to so many mistakes but
he's not a great philosopher in his own
right whereas Wittgenstein is and I
would actually say I think the reverse
is true that but again you know he's
coming out of that context and I'm
coming out of
different context I would say that that
Vidkun Stein when you plumb the depths
of what he has to say and then you
compare it to what other people have to
put on the table turns out not to be
quite so profound as as we would imagine
but there is some real depth there so
you know just because you don't have you
know the depth of Lake Michigan doesn't
mean that you're not a great lake yeah
and so the concern is a great
philosopher so what are some of the key
things that I really enjoyed or found
interesting or wanted to puzzle over in
his work so one of the biggest things is
his notion that rules always involve
some sort of interpretation and digging
into how is it that we actually do
interpret rules to make sense of them
because there's a lot of things that by
the mid twentieth century people are
considering to be just completely
rule-bound activities and therefore
entirely unproblematic like for example
mathematics the notion was if you can
just have some sort of an algorithmic
formal system then you can take all the
subjectivity all the uncertainty out of
it and Viktor Stein showed us that at
least as far as human concerns are
and that pretty much includes everything
in our world everything that we sense
everything that we make sense out of you
can't eliminate them and so it's it's
very good to be attentive to that and to
think about that and to try to see
whether the way in which we make
assumptions actually guides the way in
which we follow rules or the way in
which we learn them or the way in which
we teach them or the way in which we
enforce them he also had a great idea
with this family resemblances business
when I came to definitions a lot of
people want to try to define things by
getting at the essence of the thing and
you know when Plato got us on the road
to definitions the whole roast being
sort of a thing about it as a circle
everything that fits into that circle is
that thing and everything that's outside
of that circle is not that thing
everything within that circle has an
essence everything outside of the circle
doesn't and there are some things that
we can define that way but there are
many other things that we can't
similarly define for example the word
freedom right freedom has multiple uses
and there were other ways to try to get
at this we could talk about analogical
predication and even you know equity
equity things along those lines but bit
constrain had a nice idea in this family
resemblance business where he said for
some things really definition is much
more like noting family resemblances
everybody within the family has certain
traits but not everybody has the same
traits so there might be a certain knows
that that nine out of ten people in the
family have but the tenth person doesn't
have so it's not something that
everybody has that makes it essential or
at the at the core of it it's rather
than most of them have it
and then there could be a certain way in
which the hair falls right chin you know
and so when it comes to defining things
like freedom that may be very useful
when it comes to defining religion in
philosophy of religion a lot of people
think that the only way we can
adequately define it is by picking out
certain traits and then doing a bit
contingent family resemblance
same thing with in fascist studies or
far-right studies with defining the
actual notion on fascism you know
there's there's everyone's trying to
find the fascist minimum but it's better
to look at it in terms of family
resemblance so that's a very useful
concept to guiding us to pay attention
to our logical grammar and focusing on
the usage not the intention but the
usage of terms words of whole you know
bits of meaning like propositions or
statements or questions and then looking
at them in terms of something you
sleeves us to something else which is
context and bit Kingston wasn't the kind
of person who says well there's a whole
bunch of different contexts and and
that's all there is to it he brought out
this notion of a language game and this
starts to bring together a lot of these
these notions right because how do you
know that something is a game it has
certain rules that people have to follow
within it and that structures what the
game is so for example chess consists in
a chess board and pieces but also the
rules that govern what you can do and
they make sense within that context and
you could expand it so for example in
Star Trek you know they came up with
this 3d chess right that Spock would
always be playing and that's an
extension of the notion of chess which
we're familiar with because of the
language we can shine the language game
in the practice of playing chess
and language games can be invented they
can be specific to a certain activity or
practice they can be quite broad
you know maybe mathematics itself is is
a type of language game or maybe it's
composed of a number of different
language games but this is a very useful
concept that victim Shane came up with
she never did manage to circumscribe and
say exactly what a language tape was nor
whether there could be games within
games nor how games necessarily
connected up with each other and he left
it to that he left that to to Vicky's
angst in Ian's to sort of think about
figure out language game was not the
only conception of context that he
worked with language games are grounded
on what he called a form of life a
broader set of practices concerns
activities communities sometimes even in
which people lived out what language
games allowed them to do to
conceptualize to contest to make sense
to produce and a bit concerned also this
notion that if we if we dig down you
know we can do certain levels of
analysis eventually we hit bedrock and
we can't get any any further and we just
have a description and that description
may seem rather arbitrary to us from the
outside or even from the inside as we're
exploring our own world but then it has
its own sort of internal logic to it I
also like that victim Stein paid close
attention
- what language intersected with like
for example our feelings and not just
you know the classical passions I gave
her and sadness but our feeling of what
it meant to be certain or bewilderment
and I like that he paid attention to how
it tied in with with command and
obedience and enforcement to some degree
I like that he was interested in how
people came together in in language
games and how they might be you know
contesting things within language games
and so these were really interesting
ideas heady ideas for me and I saw
connections between these and some of
the other concepts that I was I was
playing with it at the time and learning
about in other classes and so I decided
I was going to write my master's thesis
originally on on Vidkun Stein and a
master's thesis is sort of like a small
book it could be as little as 60 pages
my master's thesis that I ended up
writing on who Cyril and distal sir and
end up being about a hundred and fifteen
pages and actually just replicating
stuff that Derrida and grimace had
already done strangely enough
but I didn't realize it anyway at first
I wanted to write on Vicky Stein and I
was really interested in this notion of
language game and I wanted to explore
something that seemed to be a big
problem in n-bit Kinston you know a lot
of it continious would say well you just
have a whole bunch of language games and
they could be in commensurate with each
other and you move from one to the next
and there's really no no stepping point
I said well that doesn't actually make
sense because that's not what our life
is like and actually that doesn't
actually that doesn't fit Vidkun Stein's
profile either
and this is my favorite book by
bekenstein my all-time favorite it
always has been and probably always will
be remarks on the foundation of
mathematics and this is the really nice
addition which has the the German and an
English facing pages you know watch my
videos I love that sort of thing and
Vidkun Stein realized that mathematics
there were two two really key things you
realize that mathematics was something
that was a very broad scope that it's
not as if if we want to talk in terms of
language games there's only one you know
use of mathematics know there's there's
multiple uses and yet we have this same
thing mathematics with a number system
and the possibility of calculation
running through all of them so how how
is that capable given victim Stein's you
might say his metaphysics using a term
that he's kind of allergic to but he
really does have a metaphysics it's just
one that's grounded in language in form
of life and that sort of thing
the other thing was mathematics had been
seen by by the Enlightenment really
really early modern philosophy all the
way through the Enlightenment to the low
justice project as being something at
least that we can be certain about and
attain some degree of exactitude and
rigor within all the other stuff is
messy but if we if we do things in a
mathematical way that will bear some
results that we can really count on and
victim science said well no it's not
that simple let's actually look at what
people do with mathematics and think
about how mathematics really works and
look how mathematicians do things
and then we won't be quite so certain
because all the human elements will
start to intrude and I'm just gonna read
you to two very short passages from from
this work he has you know a lot of very
interesting things to say
he says the propositions of logic are
quote laws of thought because they bring
out the essence of human thinking to put
it more correctly because they bring out
or show the essence the technique of
thinking they show what thinking is and
they also show kinds of thinking now
just a little bit earlier he said the
laws of logic are indeed the expression
of thinking habits but also the habit of
thinking that is to say they can be said
to show how human being thinks how human
beings think and also what human beings
all thinking so it's not what the laws
of logic are just like out there in
never-never land and we come across oh
wow now we can finally put everything
into into its place there's something
that we actually had some role in
producing and we are able to produce
them like that because somebody else had
us work on the sort of things that would
have us you know there's there's a whole
backwards progression there and they
turn out its nose as if they just you
know don't hold or anything like that
but there's a lot more going on behind
the scenes than we originally thought
and they may not have the sort of scope
that we we assume them to that we
project them onto the world is having
here's another interesting one the
philosopher must twist and turn about so
as to pass by the mathematical problems
had not run up against one which would
have to be solved before he can go
further his labor and philosophy is as
it were an idleness in mathematics it is
not that a new building has to be
erected or that a new bridge has to be
built but the geography as it is as it
now is has to be judged so this notion
of sort of getting the lay of the land
of figuring out how the streets actually
and what's going on when were we're
doing mathematics and when we're
thinking mathematically and when we're
extending mathematics and logic into all
sorts of other areas that's what that
book was really about and I found that
fascinating now I was not so interested
just in the question of mathematics I
was interested in what is the nature of
our language that we can actually
conceptualize language game what is the
nature of the language game in which we
can actually discuss language games so
there's some recursive 'ti there right
in which we can can debate about it we
can contest about it is that rule
governed or is that anything goes when
you get to this higher level and does
that higher level sometimes fall into
the lower level you know one of the
intuitions that I have that I share with
the stage a grow moss is that there is
no such thing as meta light which when
you get down to it meta language always
ends up being in subway regular language
just you know working in a somewhat
different way and having all the same
features of language and anyway I
started to try to write on this and I
was working with Donna Summer film
who unfortunately died very very early
she was a very promising Vidkun stein
scholar that we had she she had cancer
and passed away
god rest her soul and she was a good
mentor I had taken her class on history
of analytic philosophy when I took her
Vidkun stein class and we talked about
all these sorts of issues and I said I
want to write under constraints okay
let's start meeting and talking about
these things and then I would start
writing and then she would she would say
I don't know what you're talking about
I'm not seeing what you're seeing I'm
not this is not making sense to me and I
think a lot of that came because of the
fact that she was analytically trained
she had studied under people who had
studied under the constrain yeah and she
told some very interesting stories about
them because a lot of them picked up
victim signs ticks and they would think
that banging your head on the wall
philosophy integral to the task and she
kind of pushed that aside but she had a
very difficult time seeing what I was
trying to drive that and I was having a
difficult time as well articulating what
I was what I was driving at so what
ended up happening was about halfway
through the writing process she ended up
she ended up thankfully telling me this
is this is not going to work I think
that you need to find a new advisor
because I'm not able to really make
sense out of what you're doing and this
is you know I'm not able to give you any
sort of guidance and frankly I don't
know whether whether what you're doing
is actually good work or not so I ended
up casting around at first you know
there was a proposal that I should write
it on a doorknob because I've written a
good paper on
on a journo and in a class I should
expand that into a master's thesis but I
was really fascinated with language and
with with Vidkun Stein so I did stick
with the philosophy of language business
now why did I end up getting away from
Vic and Stein and why do I infrequently
read him well there's a couple reasons
one is that this therapeutic conception
of philosophy that you know the go Lola
Falana that philosophy is the disease of
which it should be the cure that the
goal is to let the fly on the fly bottle
you know that we're supposed to show
that traditional philosophical problems
aren't really problems after all and
we're just sort of puzzling about
nonsense I don't buy any of that I think
that philosophy can be therapeutic but
when it is therapeutic it doesn't do so
by dissolving problems usually or when
it does that that's because though
that's that's its beginning point what
it does is it contributes greater
intelligibility to human existence and
to the world that we live in and the
social relations and so it's it's it's
actually not something that that takes
away it's something that that unveils
that shows us the way things actually
are or at least gets us closer to the
way things actually are and lets us make
the next step so you know victim Stein's
philosophy in a lot of respects stops
itself short where it doesn't need to
and that's something that turns me off I
have to say there's a there's a sort of
claustrophobic feeling to a lot of it
Kingston's writing in my in my view and
in my experience of it and I think
that's in part because he's writing in a
impoverished and intellectually
impoverished realm of anglo-american
philosophy early 20th century where they
had you know we're gonna wipe away all
this and start anew and we're gonna just
begin by paying very close attention to
the things that we're doing and they
deprived themselves of the resources of
the great traditions philosophical
inquiry many of them did not all of them
John wisdom didn't Alice Ambrose didn't
but they were exceptions and you get the
idea that that it's almost like what
happened with with communism after the
Velvet Revolution people are like well
what do we do now everything's been
gutted we have to rebuild from the
ground up but we don't we don't have all
the things that we would normally have
we don't have a rich robust intellectual
life because of the damage that these
these people these Philistines have done
and you know it's one thing to tell
yourself you know the damage these
people have done and say well we'll just
rebuild it when you actually have the
resources that you need but Anglo
American philosophy in many respects
deprived itself of resources and and
they didn't need to because there were
people right down the street studying
Aristotle who actually made sense of
Aristotle because it took Aristotle
seriously you know or pick whoever else
you like so that's something I don't
like about about bacon Stein and I think
that Vic and Stein himself would have
benefited by reading many more people
and really taking them to heart and
making sense of them I mean he mentions
Augustine but you don't get the sense
that he actually understands much of
Augustine or thought a great deal about
Augustine and he would have benefited
greatly by that
there's a whole bunch of things that you
could you can say about that where there
there just isn't enough engagement with
the tradition there and it had there
been more he wouldn't have spent as much
time in perplexity and and reinventing
wheels Vidkun Stein because of that
doesn't really address many of the
things that I'm particularly interested
in when it comes to language and human
beings so for example you know I would
have loved to seem to consign talk much
more about emotions and at the effective
life and praxis and human beings but he
didn't do it you know he didn't write an
awful lot you know to begin with but he
you might say he spent a lot of his time
doing groundwork rather than actually
exploring things more systematically he
could have been an Aristotle but he but
he wasn't and that you know Aristotle
was a dialectical philosopher he read
and knew and pretty much everybody else
on the scene had done and knew where he
differed from them and knew exactly why
he had and could tell you why he'd gone
further and Vidkun Stein I don't see him
able to to do that on a lot of key
issues you know this notion of language
game and form of life and rule and
interpretation is really brilliant I
would have loved to have seen him talk
more about the structures of authority
within it or how these things develop
over time historically but he didn't do
that so now the other thing that I'll
say is that when it comes to philosophy
of language that consign some
contributions that I've talked about
them but a great many other people do as
well and many of them are part of that
tradition so Aristotle is one of them
you can't do philosophy of language in
my view effectively if you don't at
least know Aristotle you should also
know Thomas Aquinas
because he had a lot of great things to
say about language you should probably
know Thomas Hobbes and his views on
language and when it comes to sort of
contemporary analyses of what is going
on in the interface between language or
you know
signs and systems more broadly and life
action thought being itself there's a
lot of other people who have much more I
think to contribute and much more
straightforward structured things so if
it can shine can be a very great
clearing things away and getting us to
pay attention but to get beyond Vidkun
Stein I think that we need to you know
read Heidegger or we need to look at
structural linguists like grimace and
Helms love and you know contemporary
ones like look Umberto Eco or John
Dealey Thomas a Bock I think that we
ought to be attentive to all these these
sorts of things and so I ended up you
know I ended up seeing less and less to
get out of it Kingston I still enjoy
reading him I still enjoy teaching him
although I haven't done it for a while
and I will shoot those videos about you
know some of his works later on perhaps
this this fall so that's been another
one of my philosophical phases now you
know a little bit more about about my
history and I'll leave off there